JIM LECINSKI: Well, good
afternoon, Googlers.
I'm Jim Lecinski, Vice President
of US Sales,
actually based out of
the Chicago office.
My pleasure to be your host or
co-host for the fireside chat
Talks at Google with our guest
today, Mr. Ed Whitacre.
Ed is one of the icons of
American business, and will be
sharing with us his thoughts on
his new book, The American
Turnaround, which is a
tremendous read, and I highly
recommend it for both personal
development as well as
insights into business.
And one thing that we try to
do here at Google is always
try to develop ourselves into
better managers, and there's a
lot of good insights that
we'll be getting
into here in a minute.
But before we officially welcome
Ed, I just maybe want
to set a little bit of context
here from a Google standpoint.
We've been spending a lot of
time here at Google talking
about this notion of 10X
transformation, moon shots,
aiming high, asking big,
certainly since Larry has set
that watermark out for
us earlier this year.
And often it's like, what does
that look like to achieve 10X?
And we're actually very pleased
to have with us
someone who has done that on
more than one occasion.
We'll talk later, but when Ed
was running AT&T, if I have
the numbers right, Ed, the
revenues there went from
somewhere in the range of $9
billion to $120 billion.
So by my count, not being an
engineer or a math major, I
think you've managed
to deliver 13.334X.
ED WHITACRE: Thank you.
JIM LECINSKI: So with that,
please welcome Ed Whitacre.
[APPLAUSE]
JIM LECINSKI: So, Ed, it's a
great pleasure to have you
with us on campus.
ED WHITACRE: Thank you, Jim.
It's my pleasure to
be here, and good
afternoon to all of you.
Thank you for coming.
JIM LECINSKI: Good.
And so we've got our audience
here live, and we're
webcasting out to Googlers all
over the world, and I thought
a great way to get started is
for those folks to get to know
a little bit about you.
You spend a little bit of time
in the book talking about your
background and where you got
started, in a small town in
Texas in a railroad family.
I wonder if you could just tell
us a little bit about
yourself and where
you came from.
ED WHITACRE: Sure.
I grew up in a town
of almost 5,000
people in Central Texas--
Ennis, Texas.
My dad worked for
the railroad.
He was a union member--
really, an official of the
union for a while.
It was a railroad town.
If you didn't work for
the railroad, you
didn't live in Ennis.
And it was Southern Pacific
Railroad at the time.
I went to grade school, junior
high, and high school in
Ennis, Texas.
Didn't think I'd
go to college.
My mother convinced, as you'll
see in the book,
convinced me to go.
I went to Texas Tech.
I have a bachelor's degree
in engineering.
From there, I went off into the
telephone industry, where
I spent 44 years, and then a
couple of years at General
Motors, and I look a little
worse for the wear, I'm sure
you can tell.
But I'm here, and I feel
good, and it's a
pleasure to be here.
JIM LECINSKI: I wonder if you'd
just maybe talk a little
bit about--
even though you spent some time
as an actual practicing
engineer, if that's the right
phrase, I wonder if there's
lessons in life that that
engineering or technical
background has carried with
you through all the other
executive positions
that you've had.
ED WHITACRE: I've always
thought the engineering
degree, just looking at that,
I think, taught you to maybe
be a little more analytical,
Jim, to look at things with a
little different eye.
And I guess that's the big
lesson I got out of
engineering.
JIM LECINSKI: So we have a
phrase here that the Googlers
are familiar with called
data beats opinion.
I wonder if you would subscribe
to that, or what
that matches with your
engineering background and
experience.
ED WHITACRE: I don't know.
Opinions are pretty
fun, aren't they?
Do I have to be worried
about the data?
But certainly, data beats
opinions, and I
would agree with that.
That's true.
JIM LECINSKI: You tell, I
thought, a terrific story in
the book, in your early days
in the telephone business,
where, if I remember it
correctly, there was an issue
out on site, and you had a
repair crew out there, and you
were sort of monitoring
the situation.
And your manager had
a suggestion on
how to handle that.
I wonder if you'd tell that
story to our audience.
ED WHITACRE: I was what was
known as a repair foreman at
the telephone company early in
my career, and we had a cable
cut, which puts people
out of service.
So I was in the work center, and
my crew was out repairing
this cable.
So my boss, my manager,
came by and said,
let's go take a look.
So we drove out to the site,
which was probably five or six
miles from where I had been
sitting, waiting for these
guys to finish.
And we got out of the car and
walked over to the ditch.
It was a buried cable,
so they were putting
this cable back together.
And I looked for a little while,
turned around, and my
boss, my manager,
had vanished.
He went back to the work center
and left me out there
with my crew.
And the message was, you should
be with your people.
You should know what's
going on.
It wasn't even very
subtle, you know?
He just went off and left me.
JIM LECINSKI: And took the
car and drove back.
ED WHITACRE: Took the car and
drove back, but the message
was pretty clear.
You should stay with your
people and know
what's going on.
JIM LECINSKI: And we'll talk
about GM later in our
conversation today, but even
through in GM, that seems like
a lesson that you've practiced,
being face to face
and with your folks.
ED WHITACRE: Well, I think
that's right, and I think that
comes pretty easy for
me, pretty natural.
I like to be around people.
I like to interface
with people.
And that particular instance was
just a matter of learning,
but I certainly learned over the
years if you stay close to
your people, involved, know
what's going on-- and I don't
mean micromanage them or manage
them, but just stay
close and be aware.
In the final analysis, you and
your coworkers, you're all in
it together, aren't you?
I mean, they want the same thing
you want as a manager.
They don't want anything
different.
They want to be successful, they
want to participate, they
want to have something to do
with the success or failure,
in some cases.
They want to be involved.
And so it's just good
to be with them.
It's just the right
thing to do.
JIM LECINSKI: And that lesson
stuck through 44 years in the
phone business.
ED WHITACRE: And some more
years at General Motors.
It did.
It's a good lesson to learn.
JIM LECINSKI: Absolutely.
So thinking about some of the
other experiences while you
were in the phone business,
that industry, I guess,
experienced, putting it
moderately, transformational
tectonic changes.
ED WHITACRE: Yes.
JIM LECINSKI: I mean, we all can
think back to when MCI was
on top of the world,
and we all carried
calling cards around.
I wonder if you'd talk a little
bit about how that
landscape changed, and how you
managed to have the foresight
to stay out ahead of that.
ED WHITACRE: Well,
it's interesting.
In 1984, the Bell system,
old AT&T--
this was many years ago-- was
split into seven companies.
JIM LECINSKI: That was
Judge Green's ruling.
ED WHITACRE: Judge
Green's ruling.
And I was at Southwestern Bell,
which was the smallest
of those entities and
took care of a few
states in the Midwest--
Kansas, Oklahoma, Missouri,
Arkansas, and Texas.
And after that, it wasn't only
me, but I think several people
saw that the telephone business
is sort of like your
scope and scale matter, and the
more you have, the more
efficient you can operate.
And so I had the feeling if we
didn't get bigger, we probably
wouldn't exist long, because
somebody would come in and buy
us out or take care of
us in another way.
And so we set out early on in
my career as chairman to get
bigger, and get a lot bigger.
And through a number of
acquisitions over several
years, we went from the smallest
baby Bell to the
largest, and some accused
me of putting AT&T
back together again.
Along that way came the
wireless revolution.
In 1990, there were a million
wireless subscribers.
Now there's hundreds of
millions of wireless
subscribers.
So along the way, in so-called
putting AT&T back together, we
added a great deal
of wireless.
And of course, everybody here
certainly understands what
that means, and the data, but
it was an interesting trip,
and we made many large
acquisitions, and AT&T today
is the largest telecom
company in the world.
JIM LECINSKI: And you made,
among many big decisions, one
you made there was to change the
name of the company, which
you just alluded to.
At Google, we think a lot
about branding, brand
architecture, brand
nomenclature.
Should it be called Earth by
Google or Google Earth?
Those kinds of things.
YouTube by Google, or YouTube
as a standalone brand?
I wonder if you could maybe take
us inside some of those
conversations and meetings where
you and your executive
team were debating about
the name change.
ED WHITACRE: I absolutely can.
We started out as Southwestern
Bell Telephone Company, which
was pretty accurate.
And then we acquired
Pacific Bell.
Well, then Southwestern didn't
exactly fit, because Pacific
Bell, which is California,
is not Southwest.
It's due west, right?
So we got to thinking, well,
Southwestern Bell doesn't
work, so we changed
the name to SBC.
And people assumed that stood
for Southwestern Bell
Corporation, but in reality,
it didn't stand
for anything, Jim.
It was just SBC.
And we just picked that
because it was easy.
And then we made other
acquisitions.
We bought Ameritech, we bought
Bell South, we bought
Cingular, and we bought AT&T
Wireless, and we bought the
AT&T mother company.
We were known as SBC.
And then we acquired AT&T. And
the question was, should we
keep AT&T's name or
stick with SBC?
And as you can imagine, we'd
grown, so a lot of our
managers, a lot of our
people thought we
should stay with SBC.
And the AT&T name was damaged
in the US to some extent,
because it was known
as not giving very
good service, et cetera.
But worldwide, AT&T's name
was good as gold.
It was like Hershey, and it was
like other names that have
been around for hundreds
of years.
So we debated that for not
too long, actually.
Everybody, we took a little
poll, and it was almost
unanimous we should
stick with SBC.
But I had this brilliant flash
of light that said, this is
not a democracy.
We're going to call it AT&T.
JIM LECINSKI: So you
overruled it.
ED WHITACRE: So I overruled
everybody, and we called it
AT&T, and I think we
subsequently were glad we did.
JIM LECINSKI: Yeah.
I'd never heard that story.
ED WHITACRE: Yeah, that's
a true story.
JIM LECINSKI: Now, speaking of
your team, and maybe those in
the room, you talk a lot in the
book about the importance
of assembling a great team,
your HR folks, your deal
makers, people who've been
with you a long time
throughout your career.
I wonder if you would maybe just
talk about some of your
learnings on assembling
a team.
ED WHITACRE: Well, I have
several things I could talk
about there, and I'd like to
say first of all is that
people are the most important
part of any business, and
they're the best asset
any business has.
And if you don't know that, and
if you don't work at that,
you're not going to make it.
If you don't realize that people
are your biggest asset,
and treat them like you want
to be treated, you're not
going to make it.
And I've had that proven to
me time and time again.
Secondly is most people
are good and feel
like you and I feel.
And we all want to be
part of a company.
We want to be involved.
We want to be responsible
for something.
We want to have the authority
to do something.
We don't want to be
micromanaged.
We want to make a good wage.
And all of us have those
same feelings.
And I think when you realize
from the lowest level to the
highest level, those are the
same, I think you're way ahead
of the game.
So I think it's most important,
because I believe
management's responsible
for everything.
I'm not a Six Sigma
guy, where you put
the onus on the employees.
I believe management's
responsible, really, for
everything.
With that comes the fact that
you have to have the very best
team, and that means managers
that are people-oriented, that
are ambitious, that
are willing to
learn, that are flexible.
You can put a lot of adjectives
on that, or
adverbs, I guess.
And so you do set
out to do that.
And I encountered that in spades
in General Motors at
the upper levels of management,
where they're nice
people, and they're good people,
but they'd been there
so long they had no
adaptability.
They couldn't adapt to change,
or wouldn't change.
And when you encounter that
situation, you have to make
changes and make them quick.
You have to get everybody on
the same wavelength as you.
JIM LECINSKI: Because it
doesn't get better by
postponing the decision.
ED WHITACRE: It doesn't
get better.
And you can kid yourself a long
time and say, well, we
can work around this
or that person, or
it's really not important.
But it really is, because a bad
manager hurts everybody in
the organization.
They hurt the other thousands
of people that are there.
And so we're all kindhearted,
and we want to be nice, but
you just have to get rid of
bad managers quickly.
And some people can adapt in
a different situation.
Maybe they're in
the wrong role.
I think you owe it to
examine all that.
But you can't just sit around
with a bad manager.
You have to get them out, and
get them out quick, because
really, it's affecting hundreds
of other people.
Thousands.
It's affecting everybody
in your company.
JIM LECINSKI: And we'll talk
about some of that at GM, how
that all went down.
But I don't want to pass
by-- you mentioned
wireless and Cingular.
I think, arguably, that you were
responsible for one of
the most transformational
decisions in recent business
history, where AT&T decided to
do the deal with Steve Jobs to
be the exclusive distributor
of the iPhone.
And the fact that we're working
on Android here and
that there's a smartphone in
everybody's pocket, and the
penetration, and how it's really
transformed the world
arguably could be traced back
to that specific decision.
I wonder if you could tell us
about how that came about, the
discussions and decisions
with Steve and
your team to do that.
ED WHITACRE: Sure.
I had a guy named Stan Sigman
that ran the mobile business
for AT&T, and a very
good manager.
And he and Steve Jobs were
friends, and I met Steve a
couple of times.
But Steve had this new product
that he wouldn't show us, but
we had a private meeting in a
hotel room in New York, and it
was the first iPhone.
And he came into the
room, Stan said--
I've got one somewhere--
and he had one of these, a
mock-up, and this is my guy,
and Steve Jobs, and he had it in
his coat pocket, and it was
like he had the atomic secret.
He wouldn't pull it out,
wouldn't show it to us.
But they talked for a while,
and he pulled this out and
showed it to Stan--
the earlier one-- and
said, this can be a
revolutionary device.
Well, I guess just looking
at it, it's not
that impressive, right?
It's just a phone.
But as Steve talked, we got
pretty engaged in terms of
applications that could
be put on this.
And this was before any
applications existed.
I mean, this was just
a phone phone.
And he wanted a lot
of money for it.
And he was a very secretive,
and he wouldn't
even let us hold it.
He wouldn't let us
take it back and
look at it or anything.
He put it back in his coat
pocket and left.
Well, to make a long story
short, we had the network, he
had the phone, and we debated
this not very long that this
could revolutionize the
way things are done.
And he wanted a lot of money for
it, and AT&T pushed a lot
of chips out on the table,
if you would.
We paid a lot of
money for this.
You have to pay for it up front,
and then you get it
back monthly from
your customers.
We did that.
We pushed a lot of money.
We got an exclusive,
as you said.
And I think the rest
is history.
It was a huge gamble on AT&T's
part, because it
cost us a lot of money.
But I think we had the vision
that this could really be
something big with all the
applications, et cetera.
Nobody else would
step up to it.
We did the deal with Steve.
We got the iPhone exclusive.
I think the rest is history.
There's tens of millions of them
out there now, and it was
a very good decision for AT&T.
JIM LECINSKI: So sometimes, big
decisions like this are
made based on trusting of
the business partner.
Sometimes decisions like this
are made based on the
financials.
Sometimes it's based on frankly
having no other choice
and needing a home run.
How would you characterize
this decision?
ED WHITACRE: Well, I think we
were always aggressive and had
the ability to move pretty quick
at AT&T. I mean, it was
a big company, but we could
make a decision.
There wasn't a whole lot of
bureaucracy at the top levels.
We could move.
And I think Stan and I looked
at each other, and he said,
what do you think, Ed?
And I said, I think we ought
to give this a shot, Stan.
It was a big gamble to push
all that money out on the
table, but it had
great potential.
It could have failed.
It wasn't going to wreck the
company if it did, but it
would be a severe blow.
On the other hand, it was, I
thought, a calculated risk,
but well worth taking.
It certainly was
not a financial
decision at the time.
It was, I guess, a common sense
or gut instinct feeling
that this could be really
big, and if it hit,
let's give it a shot.
And you don't make it
in business without
some risk, you know?
JIM LECINSKI: Was the board
involved, with a 200-page
PowerPoint presentation?
ED WHITACRE: No.
No, Stan Sigman and I made the
decision to do the iPhone
deal, and we made it in my
office in San Antonio, and we
made it in about five minutes.
JIM LECINSKI: And was there any,
at that time, talk about
or concern about possible
cannibalization of your other
lines of business?
ED WHITACRE: Absolutely.
Absolutely.
And that's one of the fears you
have, and that's one of
the reluctant things that
comes up is new products
sometime cannibalize your other
profitable products.
But if you go down that road,
you're in big trouble, because
you'll cannibalize yourself
right out of business.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ED WHITACRE: We always try to
take the approach, well, this
is a good product, and it makes
a lot of money, but this
has the potential
to be better.
Let's put our resources on this,
our money, our people,
and go for some new product and
stay out ahead of the game
rather than just dying.
History's full of
stuff like that.
JIM LECINSKI: And over time, did
Steve become a little less
secretive with you and Stan and
actually let you touch the
phones in future meetings?
ED WHITACRE: Yeah, we finally
got to touch the phone.
That was a good thing.
Felt pretty good, I guess,
touching it.
Can't really remember.
But we developed a good working
relationship, and we
actually needed each other.
I think people sometimes forget
that you have to have a
network to make these
things work, as you
know better than anybody.
It doesn't just magically
happen.
You have to have a network.
And we had a great network.
We had the ability to make it
bigger, along with some of the
things that have come along,
like 4G and LTE.
But we had that network.
So he needed us,
we needed him.
Because the applications
could be big.
We felt we could get
the frequencies.
We thought the technology would
move so that the service
would improve, and we could
supply many more customers.
And that's all come to
pass, pretty much.
JIM LECINSKI: Absolutely.
ED WHITACRE: So it was
a case of he needed
us, we needed him.
We got to be good friends, and
it worked for both of us.
JIM LECINSKI: Great story.
Great story.
And the world benefits from that
decision and that meeting
in the New York hotel
room ever since.
ED WHITACRE: It does.
JIM LECINSKI: So then at this
point, we're getting close to
the $120 billion mark.
AT&T is a big success, and
you decide, Texas, ranch?
ED WHITACRE: Well, I
was 66 years old.
I'd been at AT&T 44 years.
JIM LECINSKI: Highly
successful.
ED WHITACRE: Which is--
I was there more than
you are old, most of
you, by quite a bit.
And I just thought it was
time for new leadership.
And I saw some signs in myself
that said, well, maybe you
don't quite have what
you used to have.
So I decided to step aside,
and I did, and I
have a little ranch.
And I know nothing about
cows, incidentally,
but I have a ranch.
It has a cow on it, but that's
about it, you know?
And I was retired a couple
years, and then I get this
call from the Treasury
Department.
JIM LECINSKI: Tell us
about that day.
ED WHITACRE: I got a call from
the Treasury Department that
said, Ed, we would like for you
to consider becoming the
chairman of General Motors.
And I couldn't believe
what I was hearing.
JIM LECINSKI: And this
was a cold call.
ED WHITACRE: It was
a cold call.
You must have misdialed.
You must have the
wrong number.
And I talked to the car czar for
a while, and he said, we'd
like for you to become chairman
of General Motors.
And I said, I know nothing
about cars.
I'm retired.
The answer is no.
And so that was that, and I
went home, told Linda, my
wife, who's here, and just
kind of dismissed it.
Well, the next day he called
again, and said, have you
thought it over?
And I said, not really,
you know?
I thought it was a joke.
I thought you had the
wrong number.
And I knew the person calling.
I'd met him in a
previous life--
Steve Rattner.
And I said, well, you know, I'm
just retired, and I just
don't think I'd like
to do that.
And he said, but you've got
the qualifications.
You've run these big companies,
they're unionized,
you've been through a lot of
acquisitions, et cetera.
And I said, but Steve, I don't
know anything about cars.
He said, that's even better.
That's probably a great
qualification is you don't
know anything about
the car industry.
We hung up.
Next day, he called again
and said, this is
really a public service.
This is a great American company
that's been here
through World War II,
that's helped this
country a great deal.
It means a lot to
a lot of people.
It's the largest manufacturer.
It needs to be saved.
And would you please come do
this as a public service?
JIM LECINSKI: Ed, your
country needs you.
ED WHITACRE: Your country
needs you.
And that got to me.
And so I said yes, I'll come.
JIM LECINSKI: Now, paint the
picture of GM at this point.
What kind of shape was it in?
Where were they at?
ED WHITACRE: Well, it
had gone bankrupt.
It had been declared bankrupt.
JIM LECINSKI: Which generally
means that their expenses are
exceeding their revenues.
ED WHITACRE: Yes, exactly.
It's a basic rule of
business, you know?
When your expenses are greater,
you go bankrupt.
JIM LECINSKI: Not
a good thing.
ED WHITACRE: And so I went up,
and GM was emerging from
bankruptcy the day I
became chairman.
Went through a short,
abbreviated bankruptcy.
The government bailed it out.
The taxpayer bailed it out.
You bailed it out.
Thank you very much.
I bailed it out.
We're all taxpayers.
It was our money that
bailed out GM.
But I can tell you that there
was not one dollar of private
money anywhere in the world that
would have put a nickel
into General Motors.
JIM LECINSKI: Because that's
the question that
often comes up, right?
Why couldn't they raise it
in the private market?
ED WHITACRE: There was nobody
that would step forth anywhere
in the world to put one nickel
in General Motors.
JIM LECINSKI: Because at this
point, Lehman Brothers had
collapsed, people
were nervous.
ED WHITACRE: People were
nervous, the economy of the US
was headed down, there was no
money to do a conventional
bankruptcy for GM.
And if the government hadn't
stepped in, if you hadn't
donated your money to do it,
it wasn't the jobs at GM so
much as it was the millions of
jobs that surrounded GM.
If you think about it, it has
7,000 or 8,000 parts in a new
car, or in a car.
A lot of those are made
by outside suppliers.
All those suppliers
have employees.
The job impact in this country
would have been well over a
million jobs had we
not saved GM.
It was a huge economic impact,
way beyond maybe what you read
in the paper, or what
you thought.
It was just an incredible
impact.
JIM LECINSKI: So how close
was it to not surviving?
ED WHITACRE: Well, it didn't
survive, but the government
put the money back in.
We went through a quick
bankruptcy and came back out,
and away we went.
JIM LECINSKI: So now you took
over as chairman and got on a
plane in San Antonio and
flew to Detroit.
ED WHITACRE: I did.
JIM LECINSKI: What happened?
ED WHITACRE: Well, the board of
directors was pretty new.
We had to form a new
board of directors.
We kept a couple of directors
from old GM, bankrupt GM.
They hadn't been on
there very long.
And we put our heads together
and came up with a new board
of directors from all sectors,
seven or eight people.
I started spending quite a bit
of time at GM, deciding,
sizing the place up.
But at our first board meeting,
which was in August,
right after emerging from
bankruptcy, we decided that
things had to change at
GM big time, and they
had to do it quick.
The previous chairman had
left the company.
The number two guy at GM
was appointed the CEO.
And we decided that we
give him 90 days
to make some changes--
the board did.
I was chairman.
The board decided we'd give
this individual 90 days to
make big changes in GM.
And let me tell you, it needed
lots of changes.
JIM LECINSKI: So what were some
of the things that you
saw on that list of change?
ED WHITACRE: Well, I asked
people when I first got there
at the very senior level, what
happened to this company?
What did we do wrong?
They said we did
nothing wrong.
We're OK.
Everything's fine.
The economy got us.
Wasn't our fault.
Well, then you ask the question,
why didn't it get
Ford, and why didn't it get
Toyota, and why didn't it get
all the other car companies?
Mercedes, et cetera.
They didn't really have
any answer for that.
So I found an organization
that was pretty confused,
didn't know what its vision
was, its objective.
It was a very complicated
management structure at GM.
It was matrix managed, which
meant everybody had more than
one boss, and therefore
had no bosses.
And matrix management is
supposed to be collaborative,
but you don't get much done
with matrix management,
because you've got
too many bosses.
You've got to check
with everybody.
You can't pull the trigger
on anything.
And the bureaucracy was
just incredible.
JIM LECINSKI: And you had a
pretty simple acid test where
you used to just ask, what
does this guy do?
ED WHITACRE: Yes.
And nobody could tell
me what they did.
You could ask very highest
levels, and I'd say, give me
your job description.
What do you do?
And that puzzled
a lot of them.
That was a confusing question
I was asking.
So it was really just a mess.
And these were good people,
don't get me wrong.
These are great people, very
well educated, but they'd been
in that culture so long, Jim,
and been associated with that
so long where you could do
nothing wrong, really.
And GM had gone from 50% of the
market share to less than
20%, but nothing had changed
over the years.
It was still the same mindset,
if you would.
And so right away, we
had some work to do.
JIM LECINSKI: So you asked for
a 90-day plan from the CEO.
ED WHITACRE: Right.
I asked for a 90-day plan to
make some changes, and
directed him to make
some changes, and
he didn't make them.
And therefore, he
didn't survive.
He didn't make it, nor
did a lot of the
other senior managers.
And again, they're good people,
but they couldn't step
out of the previous life
and change the
way they did things.
And so we had to put the right
people in the right jobs,
simplify the organization.
And if I don't say anything
else, remember this.
You have to give people
responsibility to do a job,
you have to give them the
authority to do the job, and
you have to hold them
accountable.
And I think people
respond to that.
We tried to do that.
We did do that.
And shortly thereafter,
good things started
to happen to GM.
JIM LECINSKI: So we'll
come to that.
I wonder if you might share--
I thought there were some
fascinating lessons for Googlers.
For anybody, in fact.
During that 90 day period, you
had some observations about
clarity of thinking, being
succinct, the use of
PowerPoint, a role for details
versus being able to
communicate at high level.
Talk a little bit about what
you saw, and as a senior
executive, what you expect in
those kinds of situations.
ED WHITACRE: Well, I'm a simple
person, so I've always
believed that simpler
is better.
And GM was just the
reverse of that.
It was not simple.
If you asked somebody a
question, you'd get a
PowerPoint presentation that
would probably last an hour,
hour and a half, 50 slides, 100
slides, most of which I
couldn't understand anyway.
And it was really just an
incredible bureaucracy.
This is what happens when people
don't have authority to
do something, when they don't
feel good about their job.
When they're not part of it,
when they're not involved,
they'll set out to make
themselves important.
And that's the way bureaucracies
grow.
So if you have somebody that
doesn't feel like they're
part, not involved, they'll make
up something so that they
do feel involved.
And so all of a sudden, you get
another test, or you get
another criteria you have to
meet that anybody can put in a
system-- a middle level manager,
a lower middle.
And I think that's partly in
response to I want to feel
important, I don't feel that
way, therefore, I'm going to
insert myself in the process.
And the bureaucracy
starts to build.
JIM LECINSKI: And the result
is, it gets worse.
ED WHITACRE: Right.
It just gets worse.
And so that had built to,
I think, an extremely
high level at GM.
Again, good people, but it was
really a confused place from a
standpoint.
Had no organization chart.
I asked for an organization
chart early on to see who
reported to who and what
functions, and they didn't
have an organization chart.
They had discontinued all that
HR activity in the name of
saving money, less cost.
And I asked people, well,
who reports to you?
And we got into this matrix
management stuff again.
Well, I have three bosses.
Well, which one counts?
That's a hard question
to answer, which
boss is my real boss?
And some of them would say,
well, it's the one that rates
me every year and I get
my paycheck from.
That would've been
my answer, too.
But there were other bosses you
had to collaborate with,
and as a result, no decisions
could be made.
JIM LECINSKI: So meanwhile,
during that 90-day period when
the CEO was putting a plan
together that ultimately
didn't pan out, you were doing
some management by wandering
around, some investigation,
table talk, if you will,
yourself to try and
sleuth a little.
ED WHITACRE: I spent a lot of
time from the very bottom to
the top of GM during
that [INAUDIBLE].
I went to a lot of assembly
plants, met with assembly line
workers, met with union members,
just got to know the
company and its people.
And that was most helpful to
me when I became the CEO 90
days later.
JIM LECINSKI: And what did you
hear about how they felt?
ED WHITACRE: Well, most of them
were very embarrassed,
Jim, because the company had
gone bankrupt, and they felt
really bad about that,
as you can imagine.
Some of them said their
neighbors wouldn't speak to
them because they had
gone bankrupt.
Their kids were sort of
shunned at school.
So the assembly line workforce
was most anxious to prove
they're as good as anybody in
the world, and great workers.
But they didn't see any way
to make that happen.
But that's the feeling they
had inside is, we're good.
Give us another chance.
We want another chance.
You just learn a lot of things
by walking around.
Goes back to that story of when
I was left with my crew,
my boss left me out there.
You can learn a great deal by
getting to know people in the
organization.
JIM LECINSKI: So then
fast forward.
It's now, I guess, December,
and the decision is made to
excuse the existing CEO
and appoint a new CEO.
ED WHITACRE: Right.
And so at the board meeting,
this was late November, 90
days later.
I said, well, OK, we've
agreed that the
previous CEO got 90 days.
90 days is up.
What do we do next?
And we had two or three
names on the list.
But the problem was, we couldn't
pay anybody, because
we were under TARP, the Troubled
Asset Plan, where the
Treasury Department said the
most anybody could make was
half a million dollars.
Well, you don't go get a top
notch CEO for $500,000.
Secondly is maybe the last thing
we needed was somebody
from outside the business
that didn't know it.
Maybe we need somebody they
identified a little bit with.
Well, I'd been around for 90
days and met a lot of people,
so maybe I could be a little
more identified with.
So we beat that back and forth
and pitched out a few names,
and then the board pretty much
in unison turned at me and
said, will you do it, Ed?
And this was pretty much
a public service, now.
There's no money
with this, OK?
And I live in San Antonio,
and I'm in Detroit.
And so what are you
going to say?
I mean, you could beat that
around for a long time, and
there weren't any internal
candidates from GM with any
credibility at that point.
I mean, they'd gone bankrupt.
There were some good people
there, but not stepped up.
So I really didn't want
to go get an outsider.
So sheepishly, I said, OK,
I'll do it for a while.
I'll do it through the IPO--
Initial Public Offering.
So I became the CEO that day.
JIM LECINSKI: So now the task or
the ultimate responsibility
of the plan rests with you.
So how do you proceed?
ED WHITACRE: Well, I had seen
early on that nobody at GM
knew what we really did.
You could ask anybody,
what do we do?
And nobody could answer you.
So I assembled all the senior
managers, and we'd made a
couple of changes by then.
Now, what do we do
at this company?
And 30 minutes later,
ended the meeting.
We decided Tom Stephens, the
chief engineer at GM--
then chief engineer--
said, well, we really design,
build, and sell the world's
best vehicles.
I liked that.
We could design, build,
and sell the
world's best vehicles.
That's pretty simple.
That's a message you could
communicate to a couple of
hundred thousand employees.
Everybody would feel good
about that, I thought.
And so we set out to tell
everybody, inform everybody,
this is a new day
at this company.
We design, build, and sell the
world's best vehicles.
If you're doing anything
that doesn't contribute
to that, stop it.
We don't want you here.
That's our new mission.
Let's go do it.
Some people couldn't
make that change.
We had to make a lot of
high level management
changes, Jim, early on.
But everybody got on
the bandwagon.
We communicated that to every
person at GM, from the lowest
level person to the highest
level person, to all the
assembly lines, to everybody
in the company.
And we started making
decisions.
We simplified the organization
chart.
No more matrix management.
We threw that out.
We had direct lines
of reporting.
We simplified the
business a great
deal in terms of structure.
We tried to put right people
in right jobs.
And away we went.
Everybody responded to that.
JIM LECINSKI: Now, one of those
vehicles in particular
is what ultimately came to
market as the Chevy Volt,
which arguably, for everyone who
woke up this morning with
a smartphone and a hybrid car,
you were responsible for both
of those kinds of decisions.
Tell us what went into the Volt,
and how that came to be.
ED WHITACRE: Well, there's
concerns about climate,
environment.
Certainly we all should
be concerned.
And when I got to GM, there was
development work going on
on an electric car.
And I drove the first
Chevy Volt.
It was very impressive, it had
a lot of power, it was
big, it rode good.
And it had one thing in its
favor, no range anxiety.
If you have an electric vehicle,
one of your big
concerns is, how far can I go
before I'm not sure I can get
back, right?
Distribution's a problem.
You can't run out and plug
them in everywhere yet.
And so the Chevy Volt
eliminates that.
The Chevy Volt can go electric
for the same length of time as
the Leaf or the rest of them,
but just in case you don't
want range anxiety, it has a
small gasoline engine which
comes on automatically and
recharges the battery.
So instead of worried can I go
40 miles or 50 miles or 60
miles, you can sort of
go unlimited miles.
So I thought that was great.
Corporately, I think
corporations have a
responsibility to try
new technologies for
mankind, if you would.
I think there's no reason not
to try new technologies.
I think you have that
responsibility.
So we did.
The Chevy Volt came out.
It cost $40,000.
We caught a lot of
flak for that.
Only cost $30,000 after
all the tax credits.
It's a terrific vehicle.
It didn't sell as many as we
wanted, but I think last year,
it sold more than
any other car.
I think it does away with range
anxieties, and I think
there'll be improvements.
It'll get better and better.
And now the Cadillac's out in
an electric version, so.
JIM LECINSKI: So was the
decision to greenlight the
Volt similar to the decision
how it was made for the
greenlight of the iPhone, or
was the decision process
somewhat different to
greenlight the Volt?
ED WHITACRE: No, it was
about the same.
Let's give it a shot.
JIM LECINSKI: At least you
got to touch the Volt.
ED WHITACRE: Right.
I could touch the Volt.
It's, let's give this
thing a shot.
We'll never know if we don't.
You can't be afraid of risk, or
you'll never do anything.
Because you can never
be certain that
something's going to work.
And a lot of things I did didn't
work, but some of them
did, like the iPhone and
the Chevy Volt worked.
JIM LECINSKI: But in both cases,
risks that if they
didn't pan out, wouldn't
take the company down.
ED WHITACRE: Right.
JIM LECINSKI: Measured risks.
Measured risks.
But you've got to take risks.
JIM LECINSKI: So I have a few
more questions here, but I'd
like to at least invite folks in
the audience, if you have a
question for Ed about any
of the topics we've been
discussing or anything else on
your mind, please raise your
hand, shout it out,
I'll repeat it.
Or there's a handheld mic
here up in the front.
You can go ahead and
come forward.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering if
you could talk a little bit
about how you found the approach
at GM of just the
different lines of businesses,
and figuring out, do you need
to keep all the different brands
or shut them down?
And how you value, like,
Pontiac-- why are they
competing with Chevy?
Why do you have them both,
and that sort of thing.
ED WHITACRE: Well, that was the
history of General Motors,
had been put together
that way.
I can't tell you the thought
processes for doing all that.
But it had, and evolved into
a lot of different
brands, as you say.
The decision, of course, to
eliminate some of them were
based on profitability, their
closeness to another design.
And so Pontiac went away,
Oldsmobile went away.
But I really can't tell you the
inception of that, except
over a period of many years,
all those brands developed.
But I don't know
the reason why.
AUDIENCE: I was more wondering
if you came in and said, it
doesn't make sense that we
have all these different
brands, and we need to
simplify things.
Because some people have talked
about GM and said, you
want to have internal
competition between the
brands, and maybe that's the
way to run a business.
And I wonder if you came in and
said, that's not the way
to run this.
We need to simplify and have
more clear responsibility, or
what you were thinking there.
ED WHITACRE: There's some of
that element in there to have
some competition.
On the other hand, there's
a lot of similarities in
vehicles, and so you could do
things in one with the same
parts from another and have
global platforms.
I guess it's just a mishmash,
an amalgamation of all that.
We had so many things to do, we
really couldn't concentrate
on deep thoughts like you're
thinking about, because we had
to start making quality
vehicles that
people would buy.
That was the number
one priority.
I really didn't stay long enough
to get into all that.
But you raise some
good points.
JIM LECINSKI: And you guys had
a sense of urgency, right?
You couldn't overthink
these decisions,
because of the clock.
ED WHITACRE: We could
not overthink.
We had to act, and we
had to act quickly.
GM had to be made profitable
again quickly, and it was.
In the first quarter after
November, we made $1 billion,
and they hadn't made any
money in five years.
So the quality overnight was
almost fixed by the assembly
line workers.
People's attitudes were
terrific, which shows you the
power of people in
any organization.
I mean, you empower them, great
things will happen quickly.
JIM LECINSKI: They'll rise
to the occasion.
ED WHITACRE: They'll rise
And all of a sudden, we started
selling vehicles again--
good quality vehicles.
AUDIENCE: Since this is an
informal chat, I'll just ask
you this question.
If you were the president of
this country, what are some
things you would do?
I think there are very few
people who can lead this
country, and you probably
are one of them.
If you were the president of
this country, what are a few
things that you would do?
JIM LECINSKI: There you go.
ED WHITACRE: The President
of the United States?
Oh my god, I hadn't thought
about that.
Well, I think you'd have
to use your own style
and do what you want.
I certainly would try to
eliminate some of the
bureaucracy upfront and some of
the I guess fighting or bad
feelings between various
factions.
I would certainly move to
empower a lot of people, and I
would make some decisions to
either start or discontinue a
lot of things, and I'd go find
the very best people I could
find to run the different
Cabinet positions, et cetera.
You know, this is a little off
that subject, but we have a
lot of managers that won't
promote or push their best
people, because they're afraid
if they do that, and their
best person moves, then their
results will fall, and they
won't look so good.
And that's a fallacy.
I mean, one of the measures
should be, how many people get
promoted out of my
organization?
Because then you're approaching
it the right way.
That's a big question you asked
me, but I'd make some
changes, and I'd make
them real quick.
And it would involve
people up front.
Lots of people.
JIM LECINSKI: I bet you'd do one
of the things that was my
favorite quote from the
book if you were
president or in any role.
In the book, you wrote, "If
you don't have the right
organization and the right
people, you're not going to
make it."
ED WHITACRE: That's true.
You're not going to make it.
AUDIENCE: I worry sometimes
about the companies in the
United States and even the
world that are too big to
fail, and GM was listed
as one of those.
And I wonder, sometimes, if it
wouldn't be better if we could
make them smaller and break
them up, and to have more
responsibility for different
pieces-- the company that
makes the motors, the company
that makes the seats.
And I think that's something
that a lot of companies face,
and I'm just interested in what
your take on that is.
ED WHITACRE: Well, I've been
asked that question before,
and I'm not sure I have
a good answer for it.
In fact, I don't have a good
answer for it, but I know a
company like GM is very
vital to this country.
And we made our own motors,
incidentally, and lots of pieces.
A lot of pieces we didn't make,
but we've made a lot of
them, like motors.
And there are a lot of other
instances in other industries
or other parts of the business
where you're too big to fail.
In my judgment, GM is
a lot smaller now.
It's substantially smaller.
GM should pay back the taxpayer
all the money.
I don't know about the concept
of too big to fail, because
most of them were in the
banking finance arena.
But I think we did the right
thing to save GM.
I don't know whether it was too
big to fail or not, but
I'm glad we saved it, because
we need a big, successful
manufacturer in the car
business, and we had one in
Ford, and I guess Chrysler's
clawing its way back.
But I don't know the question.
I've never really pondered the
question of too big to fail.
Doesn't sound right,
but I'm not sure.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
So I really liked your comments
about managers
empowering people and giving
people clear responsibility
and then holding them
accountable.
What's your advice, having gone
through 44 years at AT&T
before you were at the
senior levels--
what's your advice for people
more junior to help their
managers be like that?
ED WHITACRE: Well, you know what
the secret to success is
in business?
Just hang in there.
Just keep going.
There were many times in my
career, probably in yours,
where you get frustrated, where
you don't move, where
you think your chances
are not good.
I was on some jobs several years
without promotion, or
looking at something
different.
But I think there are
several things.
The secret to success is be
persistent, hang in there, and
keep trying.
Another key is some of
it's in your hands.
If you feel the need, go talk
to your boss and ask to do
something different.
I think it's good to do things
different in your career, do
different things, and I assume
you have the possibility of
doing that here.
And if you get tired of
engineering, go do something
else, or go try something
else.
That worked for me.
And I did some crazy things.
One time I was in New York
early in my career.
I asked to go there because I
had been in a certain job in
Texas for almost five years.
And while it was a good job, and
paid well, and had a lot
of people reporting to me,
sometimes you feel stale.
You need to do something else.
You need to step out.
So I asked to go to
New York City.
Big change.
Linda went with me.
And if you go to New York,
I know you'd hang
in there with me.
And then I was in New York for
a couple of years, and I got
this call--
this is not the way
to handle people--
got this call from a guy in the
engineering department at
headquarters that says, Ed,
we'd like for you to go to
Arkansas as the division
engineer.
He said, I want you to know
you're second choice.
Our first choice
turned us down.
Well, that's not exactly
the way you
handle human relations.
But I said, you bet I'll go.
I'll be there tomorrow
morning.
So there's a lot of factors at
play, but I think overriding
all that is never lose faith, be
persistent, hang in there,
and do the best you
can every day.
It may sound old fashioned,
but I think that works.
And don't be afraid to
try something new.
I mean, risk is a good
thing sometimes.
AUDIENCE: People say that the
road to hell is paved with
good intentions, and you want
to think that a lot of the
people on the front lines are
making decisions that they
think is right from
their world view.
And so as a manager, when you
were brought in to fix GM, how
do you take that long view and
see how far the train is about
to fall off the tracks?
And how do you keep it going
from a high level?
ED WHITACRE: Well, I think,
again, it's a people question.
I think you empower people,
you ask them to take the
long-term look, you give them
the authority to do something.
If they can't do it, you
get somebody else.
You don't play around
with that very long.
You keep moving.
You take a risk.
I don't think we ever did a deal
at AT&T, and we made many
acquisitions, where the
numbers worked.
It's about what you envision
you can make out of it.
It's not about what
you're buying,
it's what it can become.
I think that's true
of any company.
If top management has that
vision and can communicate it
and make that happen,
I think that's good.
Stay focused on that.
And sometimes it's hard
to stay focused, but
you have to do it.
JIM LECINSKI: Well, Ed, I'd like
to, on behalf of Google,
thank you for joining
us today.
Thank you for sharing
your wisdom.
Congratulations on the book.
It's "The American
Turnaround--
Reinventing AT&T, GM, And The
Way Business is Done in the
USA." Congratulations,
and thank you again.
ED WHITACRE: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]